what's up MTV morning it broke mother
what you're stepping on is a marble
foyer that was cut out of none other
than Space Mountain very red like this
coat white panda Hulk Hogan took one out
for me in China for my birthday it's
reversible
this side is bald eagle we do not change
the rear it's two million dollars it's
made out of expensive chicken dinners
I've eaten know me you'll notice here
these are some African statues I don't
really put the Africa because people are
starving to death and that's not Balder
than me come on now it's time to see my
shoe collection
you know bulbs love nice shoes everybody
got they dunks and the jords or whatever
it is they wear but see I like to cut
the middleman shoot classic I got my own
sweatshop liquor got
viki's working 16 hours right the
kitchen right what's that you say you're
a fan of archeology right here on the
bottom shelf you might recognize this as
a Tyrannosaurus Rex aid there's only two
of these left in the world
each of these bitches is four million
years old a piece son that damn brave
very hard to plan and I happen to have
both
[Applause]